يُظهر هذا الفيديو أشخاصًا في ساحل العاج
يغلقون طريقًا سريعًا رئيسيًا الشهر الماضي
احتجاجًا على إعادة انتخاب رئيس البلاد ،
وفي وقت ما بعد انتهاء الفيديو ، تم إطلاق الطلقات
في أعقاب ما كان من
المفترض أن يكون ضحايا احتجاج سلمي
راقدوا بلا حراك على
قال شهود عيان لـ هيومن رايتس ووتش إن
هناك ثلاثة أشخاص قتلوا
بعد أن فتحت قوات الأمن الإيفوارية
النار ، وتقول الحكومة إن التحقيقات
جارية لكن الرئيس
أليسان واتارا الذي تحدث حصريًا إلى CNN اتخذ قراره ،
فهذه كذبة أعطيت تعليمات صارمة
لـ  عدم استخدام قوات الدفاع
النيران البنادق وعدم
إطلاق النار على أحد من بين قوات الدفاع
، من الواضح في هذه المرحلة أن
تسمية هذا البحث كذبة
، توج إطلاق النار بسلسلة من
الاحتجاجات والعنف قبل الانتخابات وبعدها
قتل 85 شخصًا من كلا الجانبين.
مئات الجرحى
وأكثر من 15 ألف فروا من
البلاد خوفًا من عودة عنف الحرب الأهلية
التي جلبت ع  واتارا المقيم
في السلطة منذ ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان ،
يقول مؤيدو المعارضة إنه ما كان ينبغي
أن يُسمح له بالترشح لولاية ثالثة
لأن الدستور يقصر عدد الرؤساء
على اثنين فقط ،
إنه قرار يسعدني أن أتخذه اليوم
لأن البلاد كانت ستدخل في حالة من
الفوضى إذا  لم أكن
مرشحًا ، هل تفهم سبب انزعاج
بعض خصومك والكثير من الناس في
بلدك من قرارك ، لا أعتقد
أنهم يعرفون فقط
أنهم لا يستطيعون الفوز إذا كانوا يريدون الاستيلاء على
السلطة دون انتخابات ، فهم ليسوا
ديمقراطيين
في حين أن المحكمة العليا الإيفوارية
سمحت للرئيس بإدارة
اللجنة الانتخابية منعت 40
آخرين من تحديه ،
هل هذا يبدو وكأنه ديمقراطية بالنسبة لك ،
دعني أخبرك أن
الديمقراطية لا تعني أن أي شخص
يجب أن يأتي ويترشح ، فلدينا
دول شابة مختلفة
يجب على المرشحين من البلدان الهشة للغاية  أن يكونوا قادرين
على قول ما سيفعلونه للشعب
وللبلد ، قاطع المرشحون الذين سُمح لهم بالترشح الانتخابات قبل  لقد قام بالتصويت
وبعد ذلك قام بتشكيل حكومة موازية
لتنظيم اقتراع جديد ،
ذهب أحد المرشحين المنفيين إلى أبعد من ذلك
السيد وتارا هو
فنان محتال وكاذب وهو يتصرف مثل
الجاني ويجب أن يُسجن الجاني
لكنه كان أحد المنافسين الرئيسيين للوطارة.
من تم سجنه ،
تم وضع آخر قيد الإقامة الجبرية ،
لنفترض أن دونالد ترامب
قرر تشكيل حكومة لأن
بايدن
قد فاز في الانتخابات ، فسيتم
إرساله إلى السجن على الفور وهذا
ما نفعله
في كوت ديفوار مراقبو الانتخابات
من  وجد مركز كارتر الأمريكي
مخاوف جدية بشأن القيود المفروضة على
الحريات المدنية
وحرية التعبير والحق في
التصويت والترشح
والتي هددت بالتراجع عن التقدم الديمقراطي
ولكن يبدو أن بقية العالم غير
مستعد لإثارة ضجة
ولا حتى فرنسا التي لديها روابط قوية مع
مستعمرتها السابقة
مع حالة حديثة نسبيًا من
الحرب الأهلية في عام 2010 فقط و 11
في البلاد وقبل الانتخابات كانت
هناك إمكانية حقيقية
للعودة  بالنسبة إلى ذلك ،
أعتقد أنه كان يُنظر إليه على أنه من الأفضل
قبول ما هو موجود وما يعرفه الناس
بأنه قد تم التضحية بالديمقراطية
باسم الاستقرار ،
أعتقد أنه من العدل أن أقول إنه نعم
في الوقت الحالي على الأقل هناك سلام في ساحل العاج على
الرغم من حقيقة  قد تكون الحرب مع
الديمقراطية نفسها
سكوت ماكلين سي إن